hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
I am so excited because I absolutely
love October and guess what it is it's
October I love Halloween it's one of my
favorite things ever and I love making
Halloween treat I could a whole week
long of Halloween treats once and I'm
not doing that again cuz that was a lot
of work and that's something that I
don't like but what I do like our treats
so we're gonna make something really fun
today these are little ghosts
ice cream cone cupcake things so what
we're gonna need are some ice cream
cones and make sure you get the ones
with like the flat bottoms because I've
made a really big mistake when I first
bought these they had the pointed tips
and guess what you can't do you can't
stand up the ice cream cones and that's
not gonna work for what we need to make
today next we need to make a cake let me
make sure this isn't expired January
2018 we're in business
so today we're gonna be making this cake
in a blender I've got a lot of requests
to bring the blender back so guess what
it's back if you're new here and you're
wondering why is this girl making a cake
in a blender then obviously you're new
here welcome to the family I appreciate
it so we're gonna I'd like to give you
guys a tip when making things that
you're not supposed to make it a blender
always put the liquids in first those
liquids include 1/4 cup of water should
I say 1/4 cup that that I said it's
supposed to be 1 in 1/4 cup yep okay in
you go
3 eggs - no there's a shell oh god I got
a dive in here I'm gonna unplug this
because
I've seen way too many horror movies
okay well we're gonna leave that in
there and here we go we're making a cake
in a wonder that scared me so bad I was
not ready
the problem of making cakes in the
blender is they do sometimes get stuck
to the side here so you just gotta get
in there real good give it a little
scrape
Bradley making cupcakes inside of ice
cream cones and it's pretty much the
coolest thing ever
here's our mixture so get yourself a
cupcake tin like this one open up your
ice cream cones you just put them in
here like little cupcakes Oh oops
so spooky now we're going to be pouring
in our mixture that's why I decided to
use the blender because this is great
because you can just pour in the mixture
cupcake batter
don't fill it up too high because it
will overflow
yeah I'd say like maybe like 3/4 there's
a little line here so I'm just kind of
filling it up to that they're gonna
pre-heat your oven to 350 or something
about that around there 375 15 yes boy
do your job alright scream cone cupcakes
for the oven and now we're going to be
prepping our icing I'm gonna be using
Rosanna's little icing piping bags I'm
so excited these the first time we would
be using them this is why I use knives
these scissors are worthless so I wanted
kind of a bigger tip because I want it
to look kind of like soft-serve icing
ice cream icing icing I'm using icing
I'm making ice cream this is super
fluffy holy crap yeah get in there
this is so cute this ro has these little
hearts on here and they're actually
functional hearts because you're not
supposed to fill it past that I thought
I would be nice to do a little orange
icing so for that we're gonna add a
little that's a lot we'll add some more
might as well a little bit of food
coloring to that one and then I'll just
mix it up I definitely don't recommend
doing this because I've done it before
and it made a really big mess but you
know what
that is very orange
[Music]
like I just want to cry Alexa
Hansel it's all over my phone like it's
all over my phone oh my god oh my god oh
my body I'm just like I'm not sure what
- did she shoot you like when the kids
say I'm shocked like I'm legit shook
it's all over
it's everywhere Wow okay well I guess I
could take my cupcakes out of the oven
and I'm gonna clean up a little
hey you can't do that I don't know much
love shoot this is supposed to be the
easiest video this is this is
unfortunate getting very no Clorox wipe
my body it's fine
cool looking great mmm beautiful little
girl now I see why Rachael Ray doesn't
wanna happen
why even give a crap now know what's
coming now Wow
oh god it's so Kapono get out get back
in there I think they're fairly cooled
off so now all we have to do is decorate
I mean that's should be the easy part
right I'm only gonna well man this is
gonna run all over the place if you're
watching this video till I get an actual
inspiration for Halloween treats
hopefully it goes yeah looks like
Jonathan goes oh I'll put a little
justice beauty
like Maddie do not fall over spooky
spooky orange this is really great icing
like I really like it a lot
oh it's dripping off the slide it's
melting like actual ice cream
spooky eyeball number two oh my gosh I'm
squeezing this so hard I don't make him
have a smile I don't never say I didn't
try cuz obviously it these looks super
cute mildly impressed but not really
that impressed cuz it's actually not
that good that's a lot of icing I mean
like an entire canister for like for
Halloween sprinkles that I got at the
craft store I'm gonna do this over the
trashcan because I am very sanitary oh
my gosh these purple sprinkles are
incredible upsets a lot good thing I'll
have a bake shop because the health
inspector would be here right now
knocking on my door what are you doing
what are you doing this one is a little
bit he doesn't even matter this is a
little crooked you put some of these on
here these are some super spooky springs
what is that
I tried like if you even say that I
didn't try I really did oh my god it
just looks like ants that's ugly don't
do that oh these have little purple ones
in them too I'm literally decorating
cupcakes over a trash can
yeah normally I like to try my treats
but to be fair this is a brainy trash
bag I didn't have enough icing for these
to say I could just scoop this up off
the floor of this there we go
I'll just add some icing here I'm so sad
I thought these were gonna be so cute
they look garbage well guys that's it
unfortunately that's all I have for you
I do think that some of these actually
look kind of nice like this one looks
kind of good
this one looks okay if you like look at
it a certain angle but ghosts definitely
do not turn out the way that I thought
like I just gave up on those look look
at this alright well thanks for watching
happy all the Halloween look for some
more Halloween themed cooking videos in
the coming weeks and hopefully or
depending upon what type of videos you
like maybe there will be more messes I'm
not sure yeah that's all I have to say
okay bye
Oh God Wow while we was a solid effort
though I will get myself an A for effort
[Music]